Вітаю, з вами Олена Соляник –
викладачка біології школи «Майбутні».
Сьогодні у курсі генетики з 10-м класом ми
розберемося з антимутаційними механізмами,
і з тим, яким чином геном людини
захищається від шкідливих впливів.
Почнемо ми з такого факту: в нашому
організмі близько 30 трильйонів клітин,
теоретично, кожна з них може мутувати.
Чому ж ми досі живі?
Чому ми доживаємо до
доволі-таки поважного віку,
і дехто з нас навіть
лишається при цьому здоровим.
Причин декілька. Перша з них –
нас рятують антимутаційні системи.
Те, що відбуваються
мутації і це природньо,
і це процес, який протікає
постійно – не секрет.
Наш організм, і інші організми
до цього процесу пристосувалися.
Організм захищає себе від впливу
різноманітних шкідливих чинників.
Інший факт криється у тому, що, насправді,
не всі мутації ми передаємо нащадкам.
На минулому занятті ми
трішки торкнулися цієї теми,
а сьогодні я хочу поговорити
про це докладніше,
а саме – про факт, що ті мутації, які
відбуваються у соматичних клітинах,
ми своїм нащадкам не передаємо.
Уявіть собі гіпотетичний
організм, де внаслідок мутації
пошкоджується генетичний матеріал,
клітина порушує клітинний цикл.
Внаслідок цього розвивається
якесь онкологічне переродження.
Виникає рак якогось там органу.
Чи здатен такий організм
передати цей рак своїм нащадкам?
Звичайно, що ні.
Тому що ми не розмножуємося клітинами
печінки, клітинами нирок або іншими.
Ми розмножуємося лише
завдяки статевим клітинам,
тому, щоб щось потрапило
до наступного покоління,
воно має потрапити
саме до статевої клітини.
Насправді, тут ситуація ще цікавіша.
Цікавіша вона тим, що при
такій передачі нащадкам,
жінки ризикують набагато
більше за чоловіків.
Чому? Правда криється в
процесах формування статевих клітин
та у відмінності формування
статевих клітин у чоловіків і у жінок.
Якщо, наприклад, жінці 30 років,
то її яйцеклітинам у яєчниках –
тридцять з половиною років. Чому так?
Тому що, коли розвивається жіночий
ембріон всередині організму матері,
статева система цього ембріону
закладається на п’ятому місяці
вагітності матері цією дитиною.
Тобто, закладається вона раніше.
Максимальна кількість яйцеклітин,
якщо цей ембріон жіночий
і це майбутня дівчинка, буде
в її яєчниках на тому етапі,
коли ця дівчинка ще не народилася.
Потім ті яйцеклітини, з
якими дівчинка народжується,
існують з нею до закінчення
продуктивного віку жінки.
Тобто, протягом всього життя,
якщо у жіночому організмі
накопичуються якісь зміни, мутації,
то ці мутації, теоретично, можуть
торкнутися і статевих клітин.
Чим довше ми живемо,
тим вищий такий ризик,
та саме тому жінкам після певного віку
вже не рекомендують народжувати дітей,
оскільки є великий ризик
народження дитини з патологією.
Наприклад, жінки віком більше
сорока років, які хочуть народити дитину,
їм рекомендують пройти обстеження
щодо ризику народження
дитини із синдромом Дауну.
Чому так? Тому що в жіночому
організмі жіночі статеві клітини
всі зміни накопичують протягом життя.
Нових статевих клітин у жінок не виникає.
Ми живемо з тим багажем,
з яким ми народилися.
Якщо жінка має якісь шкідливі звички,
які можуть нашкодити її статевим клітинам,
то ця ситуація ще більше
погіршує таку картину.
Давайте порівняємо, що
ми маємо з чоловіками.
Якщо ми маємо чоловіка віком 30
років, то його сперматозоїдам 100 днів.
Тобто, у сім’яниках чоловіка продукція
сперматозоїдів відбувається постійно
з моменту його статевої
зрілості і до самої смерті чоловіка.
Повне оновлення сперматозоїдів в організмі
відбувається приблизно за 100 днів.
Оскільки сперматозоїди довго в
організмі не живуть і не існують,
то вірогідність того, що вони зможуть
накопичити якісь шкідливі мутації,
ця вірогідність надзвичайно низька.
Це підтверджується,
наприклад, таким фактом,
що ліквідатори аварії
на Чорнобильській АЕС,
які лишилися живими, і які потім мали
дітей, то були здебільшого здорові діти.
Оскільки через певний час після
аварії пройшло вже оновлення тканин,
клітин, сперматозоїдів, і у
чоловіків не було ніяких проблем.
Тобто, якщо не пошкоджені самі сім’яники,
то зі сперматозоїдами все буде нормально.
Яким же чином можна порушити ДНК?
Що відбувається під час мутацій.
Ми вже це трішки розбирали
на минулому занятті
і зараз поговоримо про це докладніше.
Для цього, знову ж таки,
доведеться намалювати
гіпотетичний ланцюжок ДНК з
якимись гіпотетичними нуклеотидами.
Нехай буде так.
Перша модифікація, перша
зміна, яка може відбуватися з ДНК –
це хімічна модифікація нуклеотиду.
Тобто, сам нуклеотид лишається на місці,
а азотиста основа цього
нуклеотиду пошкоджується
і, таким чином, при зчитуванні
такого генетичного коду
можуть виникнути проблеми. Може
відбутися заміна або втрата нуклеотиду.
Наприклад, втратили
гуанін ось в цій позиції.
Можуть утворитися внутрішньониткові
зшивки між нуклеотидами, яких не має бути.
Ви пам’ятаєте, що комплементарні
нуклеотиди з’єднані між собою
водневими зв’язками, і ці нуклеотиди
мають знаходитися на різних ланцюжках.
Якщо трапляється однонуклеотидна
зшивка, наприклад, ось таким чином,
то ми вже кажемо про
якісь мутаційні ефекти.
Міжниткові зшивки
також можуть утворитися.
Це, наприклад, ось так.
Така зшивка, звичайно,
призведе до зміни структури ДНК,
і така ДНК не буде правильно копіюватися,
із неї не буде правильно
зчитуватися інформація.
Тобто, це є проблема. Можна
пошкодити самі нитки (самі ланцюги ДНК).
При цьому можна пошкодити одну нитку,
відбудеться однонитковий
розрив, наприклад, ось так,
або може відбутися двонитковий
розрив. Наприклад, ось так.
Що з цим робити взагалі?
Наскільки критичні такі зміни, до яких
наслідків вони взагалі можуть призвести?
Як все це полагодити? Є різні
рівні реагування на таку ситуацію.
Перший рівень реагування:
будемо ремонтувати,
тобто, в нашому організмі є
системи, є спеціалізовані ферменти,
які слугують для того, щоб
деякі дефекти у клітині лагодити,
наприклад, якщо ми маємо змінений
нуклеотид або втрачений нуклеотид.
Я поверну в цьому
ланцюжку гуанін на місце.
Оскільки ми казали про
однонитковий розрив,
то ці ферменти впізнають місце розриву.
Можуть впізнати за рахунок того,
що лишився компліментарний
нуклеотид на іншому ланцюзі ДНК,
і зможуть добудувати правильний
нуклеотид в правильне положення.
Набагато складніше зробити
репарацію, тобто ремонт,
у тому випадку, якщо ми
маємо двонитковий розрив.
Його дуже важко лагодити,
оскільки незрозуміло,
які ж саме нуклеотиди були
втрачені і що нам з цим робити.
На другому рівні реагування
розвивається такий механізм,
як толерантність до втрат.
Тобто, ми не знаємо, що ми втратили
і нуклеотиди, замість втрачених,
будуть добудовуватись ось в цей ланцюг
за рандомним принципом, тобто, будь-які.
Я намалювала так, вбудувавши
два комплементарні нуклеотиди,
але я не знаю які там були до
цього, і чи буде воно працювати.
На третьому рівні реагування,
якщо ми щось не можемо полагодити,
якщо відбулися такі зміни, з якими
наші системи репарації не справляються,
то така клітина має бути знищена.
Запускаються процеси апоптозу,
тобто, запрограмованої клітинної
смерті, і клітину з ушкодженим геномом
руйнують для того, щоб вона не спричинила
якусь патологію на рівні організму.
Дійсно, патологія
розвивається, якщо всі ці системи
не спрацьовують з якихось причин.
Насправді, це також вірогідна ситуація,
але вірогідність такої ситуації низька.
Як приклад, розповім вам
історію про рак молочної залози,
яєчників і простати, які
розвиваються внаслідок ушкодження
ось таких ось систем репарації, які
відповідають за сталість нашого геному.
Є здорові клітини молочної залози,
яєчників, простати, є пошкоджені клітини.
Пошкоджені клітини – це клітини, які
здатні до онкологічного переродження
і здатні провокувати
розвиток ракових захворювань.
Є гени, які відповідають
за те, щоб лагодити
зламані ділянки ДНК всередині цих клітин.
Це гени BRCA-1, BRCA-2, CHECK.
BRCA-1 і BRCA-2 – це гени, які займаються
репарацією саме двониткових розривів,
тобто, вони лагодять молекулу в
тому місці, де вона була розірвана,
а ген CHECK виконує контроль, перевіряє
чи наявні у клітині якісь уражені ділянки,
які потребують втручання генів
BRCA, які всю цю систему полагодять.
Однак, гени BRCA також, як і гени CHECK,
і всі інші ділянки молекули
ДНК, можуть бути ушкоджені.
Якщо ці гени з якихось причин ушкоджені,
вони не працюють, то у
такому випадку ризик розвитку
онкологічного переродження
надзвичайно зростає.
Ну і варіантів у пошкодженої клітини два:
або її розпізнають клітини
нашої імунної системи,
запустять систему
запрограмованої клітинної смерті
і таку клітину знешкодять,
або вона лишиться і буде
провокувати розвиток раку.
Чи обов’язковий цей
процес? Звичайно, що ні.
На щастя, не кожна мутація
напряму спричиняє розвиток раку.
Давайте роздивимось ось таку
ситуацію. Маємо здорову людину.
Тут я намалювала умовно клітини.
Я їх намалювала три,
звичайно, як ви розумієте,
в молочній залозі не три клітини
і в яєчниках теж не три клітини.
Що ми маємо пам’ятати, що кожен
ген в нашій клітині представлений
альтернативними алелями, які ми
одержуємо від батьківських форм.
Тобто, якщо відбуваються
якісь мутаційні зміни,
то вони торкаються одного
алеля, а інший алель лишається.
Ось, в одній із клітин трапляється
мутація, гени BRCA пошкоджені,
немає кому займатися репарацією.
Чи призведе це до розвитку раку? Ні.
Тому що лишається друга алель –
здорова, в якій гени BRCA працюють.
Таким чином, ця клітина
продовжуватиме функціонувати нормально.
Знайомимось з другою ситуацією.
Це ситуація із неспадковим раком.
З розвитком неспадкового
раку молочної залози.
Маємо клітини і так трапилося,
вірогідність цього надзвичайно низька,
але трапилося, що в одній
клітині пошкоджені обидва алелі.
Тобто, всередині цієї клітини,
гени репарації не працюють,
і тоді ризик розвитку
переродження, звичайно, зростає.
Зрозумійте, серед багатьох тисяч
клітин молочної залози або яєчників,
вірогідність потрапляння однакової мутації
в обидва алелі всередині однієї клітини,
це досить така малоймовірна ситуація.
Якщо вже розвивається переродження,
то воно розвивається в більш похилому
віці, тобто, мутації мають накопичитись.
Третя ситуація з
розвитком спадкового раку.
У випадку спадкового раку,
організм вже одержує клітини
з одним пошкодженим алелем.
Так, для того, щоб розвилося
переродження цих клітин,
достатньо однієї мутації, яка
пошкодить інший алель цього гену,
і в такому випадку будемо мати підвищений
ризик розвитку онкологічних захворювань.
Ви бачите, що вірогідність розвитку
раку зростає навіть до 80-ти відсотків.
Тобто, клітина без цих генів BRCA
взагалі не може нормально функціонувати.
До речі, цю патологію носіння пошкодженого
алеля гену BRCA можна протестувати.
Зараз генетичні
лабораторії цим займаються.
Можна цьому запобігти. Яким чином?
Як правило, таким жінкам
пропонують видалення молочної залози.
Ну і хто читав новини про знаменитостей,
то мабуть, знаєте що Анджеліна
Джолі пішла саме таким шляхом.
Після дослідження вона виявила,
що є носієм ушкоджених алелів
і просто не стала чекати, коли почне
розвиватися онкологічне переродження
і позбулася молочних залоз
для того, щоб не ризикувати.
На такій цікавій ноті, сьогодні
ми завершуємо наше заняття.
Я, знову ж таки, пропоную вам
розібратися з цікавим і складним питанням,
а на наступному занятті ми
продовжимо вивчення медичної генетики.
Отже, завдання буде таким.
Наголошую, що в питанні
ідеться саме про геномні мутації.
Питання було про мітохондрії.
Я розповідала про те, що мітохондрії
є нащадками вільноживучих
альфапротеобактерій.
Відносно альфа-протеобактерій,
геном мітохондрій сильно скорочений,
як ви думаєте, чому? Насправді, логічно.
Праві були ті з вас, хто
написав, що альфа-протеобактерії
живуть у більш різноманітних
умовах довкілля, відносно мітохондрій.
Альфа-протеобактерії у природі
зустрічаються в різних біотопах,
і, звісно що, стикаються з
різними умовами довкілля.
На ці умови довкілля
треба якось реагувати,
реагувати якимись механізмами
синтезу якихось речовин.
Тому має бути генетичний
матеріал, що ці процеси забезпечить.
Мітохондрії же всередині нашої клітини
знаходяться у відносно сталій системі,
тобто, постійний склад цитоплазми,
доволі обмежена кількість метаболітів.
Саме тому немає необхідності
тримати великий геном
і синтезувати велику кількість
продуктів. Тому мітохондрії
частину свого геному взагалі втрачають, а
частину – передають до ядра самої клітини.
Таким чином, ядро вже регулює
процеси синтезу у мітохондріях.
Ось таку відповідь я
хотіла бачити від вас.
Питання домашнього завдання стосувалося
модифікації в нашому організмі.
Чому різні модифікації
значно різняться у різних людей
у випадку одних якихось змін і майже
не відрізняються у випадку інших змін.
Наприклад, розміри серця та нирок.
Справа у нормі реакцій. Норма
реакцій для маси тіла широка,
тобто, ми можемо
варіювати в своїй масі тіла.
Для дорослої людини – від
мінімум тридцяти кілограмів
до майже трьохсот
кілограмів, відомі і такі випадки.
Тобто, це норма широкої реакції людини,
що у будь-якому випадку може вижити.
Що ж стосується розміру серця або розміру
нирок, то тут ситуація дещо складніша –
це настільки критичні для
нашої життєдіяльності органи,
що норма реакції доволі вузька.
Тобто, люди збільшують масу свого тіла
не за рахунок того, що
збільшуються органи,
а за рахунок того, що відкладається жир.
Розміри серця і розміри нирок
залежать від внутрішнього об’єму
людського організму,
а він приблизно сталий,
приблизно однаковий
у всіх дорослих людей.
Тому ці органи сильно
варіювати у розмірах не можуть.
Тут просто вузька норма реакцій.
Якщо розміри або вага цих
органів виходить за межі цієї норми,
то це вже серйозна патологія, і
вона призводить до смерті особини.
Тобто, у всіх живих
організмів критичні органи,
ось такі, які наведені тут, більш-менш
однакові.
Питання про вітамін С.
Чому примати його втратили і чому вижили,
а інші організми його
синтезують всередині себе.
Тут, насправді, питання дуже
просте, і відповідь також дуже проста.
Треба проаналізувати те,
чим харчуються примати
і те, чим харчуються ті ж, наведені
у прикладі, хижаки родини котячих.
Примати є всеїдними тваринами,
тому споживають достатню кількість
фруктів і достатню кількість рослинної їжі
для того, щоб отримувати вітамін С з їжею,
тому для них втрата такого гену
виявилась просто некритичною для життя.
Примати живуть і будуть жити далі, якщо
не змінять свою дієту докорінним шляхом
і не стануть, наприклад, плотоїдними
хижаками. Звісно, що цього не відбудеться.
Із хижаками ситуація складніша.
Вони не харчуються рослинною їжею,
тим паче, не харчуються фруктами.
Тому, якщо навіть така
мутація відбудеться,
то це буде несумісне з життям явище,
і вони просто, завдяки дії природнього
добору, елімінуються із популяції.
На цьому дякую.
До зустрічі!